this is the jocko underground podcast
number two with echo charles and me
jocko willink
and if you haven't caught wind of this
yet
we have a little underground movement
going
you can join the movement by going to
jacounderground.com
some
additional information that we're
putting out
the reason we're putting it out in this
format
in this
protected format
is that the right word sure
is because there's some censorship
censorship happening in the world right
now
from a bunch of different angles social
media traditional media podcast
platforms
video platforms and we've been good
for the most part
we've had some brushes
i guess we could say but
we just
have to be cautious
and make sure that we have a contingency
plan
in case things go real sideways so
that's what we're doing
and with that our last one was was about
cognitive biases and we're continuing
down the path of talking about cognitive
biases we've got some more to cover
let's start off with oh yeah and these
these cognitive biases that we're going
over they come from a website
which is
the visual capitalist dot
giving credit where credit is due
it's pretty simple and straightforward
um one of these cognitive biases
is called the forer effect or also known
as
the barnum effect and it says we easily
attribute our personalities to vague
statements even if they can apply to a
wide range of people and this is the
whole horoscope thing
whenever people ask me i always tell
them some random
thing and they go oh you i knew you were
a scorpion
i knew you were whatever
libra whatever and then they're they're
they get all excited
they get all excited and what i'll
actually i'll go too deep
i'll go i'll say um they'll i'll say i'm
oh i'm scorpio and they go oh i knew it
i knew it now i'm just kidding i'm not a
screwdriver what
and i got no i'm capricorn and they go
oh oh i get it yeah totally yeah
capricorn would do that yeah yeah
exactly
so i don't buy into that thing have you
ever buttoned no
never no even
my dad is heavy heavy into it i don't
know if he believes like believes it or
if that's just a recreational thing
which can can be the case you know right
he's the kind oh he'll first thing out
of his mouth let me ask you this what if
you were a a bad person and you were
running that
running one running the whole thing if
you were if you were writing those
things up in the newspaper
this is going to be a terrible month for
you
threats on all sides
you are doomed right
because people kind of it's a little bit
of a self-fulfilling prophecy i think is
what people hope for yeah right this is
gonna be the best month financial
rewards yeah right
yeah in a way right i mean there is
function when you think when you put it
that way a self-fulfilling prop prophecy
because that's a thing right placebo
like these are all like
essentially self-fulfilling prophecies
in that way good or bad so if you're
like hey you know what and i'll pull
this on my kids a lot be like hey you
know what's good about you like you're
like straw like you don't give up easy
that's such a and they'll be like oh you
know no same deal so yeah the horoscope
it can be the same thing and they're
usually like oh this thing says vague
you know but at least it makes you feel
good
better than making you feel bad i guess
yeah
i'm not into him yeah that's weird i
don't i don't think i ever was into you
know my dad will he'll like hey you're
oh you're on the cusp like you tell him
your birthday he'll be like oh you know
holiday whatever he won't ask for it but
like if you offer up when your birthday
is that's the first thing out of his car
oh capricorn oh on the cusp oh that you
know like when you're kind of
like bruh all right but yeah you ever
seen those experiments they do like you
can watch videos about them no where
they're like sociological or psycho
whatever and they'll um
see what i'm saying
no no they'll get a group of people and
they'll and they'll be like um
they'll give them one of the horoscopes
right and they'll give them all the same
one
and then they'll say hey okay raise your
hand if your horoscope
applied to you right or or if you think
you got your horoscope or something like
that everything exactly but it's
essentially that
and everyone raises their hand or most
people raise their hand and they kind of
they have different rounds and different
methods
of doing it and they do it and it
essentially proves or shows strong
evidence we'll say that yeah it applies
to everyone all you got to do is be like
read it and
yeah it applies to me because your brain
finds ways for it apply to you oh you're
um
you're not easy to
to
you have a hard shell but once you get
in there you have a big heart like that
kind of stuff you know where it's kind
of like
no one's really gonna that's the most
generic thing ever yeah and it kind of
applies to everyone if you just think
about it in one way or another because
you can just kind of morph your real
self around that it's kind of yeah
that's true
i have a lot of friends but you know
they don't know the real me you know
like that kind of stuff
oh there's echo charles reading his
arsenal keeping it real
uh the dunning-kruger effect
the less you know the more confident you
are the more you know the less confident
you are francis confidently assures the
group that there is no
kelp in ice cream
they do not work in the dairy industry
interesting uh my best example there was
a really good marine
who was like kind of a legendary marine
and he started training jiu jitsu
and he he had this realization like he
was real confident before he started
training jiu jitsu and then once he
started training into he was kind of
thinking yeah i'm not as badass as i
thought i was yeah that's the same with
everything yeah it seems like yeah it
seems like that one you can
understand it when you just think about
it for a second because you know how
like
and jiu-jitsu how you say it's like
that's a good example because before you
get in there and really understand it oh
yeah you just have this idea of like
yeah i can imagine wow well i would
never let you pull my arm over there i
would just stop that from happening
it's like you don't know what you don't
know kind of thing versus when you're
when you are competent like super common
you know how much you know but you know
how much there is to know and you don't
know anything kind of an attitude that's
one one thing that's nice about you know
when jiu jitsu
i would say jiu jitsu probably taught me
this i may have had some inkling of it
but man then you realize it's the same
with everything man i don't know nothing
about nothing like you start looking at
any sort of
sort of world
right and you go i don't actually know
anything about that you think you do but
then you if you do jujitsu you go i did
i thought i knew about that i didn't
know anything so therefore i don't know
anything about
other
worlds
have you other subjects
yeah have you um
can you remember a time that this
applied to you and you came to that real
realization
i mean jiu jitsu is the most obvious one
yeah
yeah jiu jitsu is
boxing is like that too boxing is like
the oh muay thai
the first time i sparred a legit muay
thai guy
yeah because it's like you know muay
thai striking is kind of linear yeah
it's kind of linear yeah it's just
you're either kicking or you're punching
it's pretty air yeah i can throw i i th
this guy might was mike right now he's a
badass like real muay thai guy and i
would start to throw a kick and he would
either
just kick me before i could kick him
or he would just be just waiting to
check it
you know
i was thinking um
basically in in boxing and in in muay
thai
the same way a white belt gets destroyed
in jiu jitsu is the same way if you
don't know how to box you're getting
destroyed there is a little bit of a you
know look we have a puncher's chance and
all that stuff
so there is some level of
primal fighting that a human can
naturally do that will be more effective
than the primal the primal fighting that
you do in jiu jitsu is counter it's
wrong it's the wrong you're doing the
wrong thing
in boxing and muay thai at least it's
in the same zone yeah
yeah
that's true
uh anchoring
we rely heavily on the first piece of
information introduced when making
decisions
yeah first impression yeah and and i
talk about this one a lot from the from
the fact of what you learn the first way
you learn something is the what becomes
the de facto proper way you anchor to
that subject i always talk about guys in
their first sealable platoon
whatever however you learn something in
your first seal balloon that's what you
think is right if you're not careful
if you're careful you go you know what
my platoon chief maybe wasn't right
about everything yeah
if you're not careful you're like
there's way you do it yeah
same thing with jiu jitsu same thing
with anything you've got to be careful
of that one
got to be suspect
automation bias we rely on automated
systems sometimes trusting too much in
the automated correction of actually
correct decisions
your phone auto corrects it's to it's
with an apostrophe
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to
jockonunderground.com and subscribe and
we're doing this to mitigate our
reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better communications with us
strengthen this legion of troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and eighteen cents a month
and if you can't afford to support us we
can still support you just email
assistance at jockowunderground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then
we will see you
mobilized
underground